joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji jackson has been in confirmation
hearings for three days during which
time she has refused to say when she
thinks life begins
she pled ignorance when she was asked
what a woman is
and she defended her extremely light
sentencing record for pedophiles
it has not been a great first week for
her and democrats are now scrambling to
stop the bleeding as the chairman of the
proceedings dick durbin demonstrated
yesterday when he refused to let the
judge
answer a simple question from ted cruz
your child pornography possession crime
was egregious in the court's view okay
so this is a bad one if you're actually
sentencing defendants you said this was
egregious
what did you set in stuart for the
guidelines said 97 121 months prosecutor
said 97 months you said it's agreed just
six thousand seven hundred images
you come in with fifty seven
in the stewart case do you want to
address that
does she want to address that
no she does not want to address that
judge jackson had already lost her
temper as republicans focused in on her
strange record of letting pedophiles off
the hook but she didn't even have the
chance to address the record by
responding to cruz's question because
dick durbin started talking over both
her and cruz and did everything that he
could to move on
you're not recognized senator senator
you don't want her to answer that
question you wouldn't allow her mr
chairman she may answer the question
i've asked her why she sentenced stewart
i'm senator by two minutes why she said
because you've interrupted me for two
minutes mr chairman will you allow her
to answer the question or do you not
want the american people to hear
why with someone she described as an
egregious appoint senator where you get
a little bit chairman durbin will you
allow her to answer the question you
want to allow her name i i will happily
allow her to why are you not allowing
her to answer the question there's not
another senator here who has not allowed
her to answer the question i'm not
asking another question but allow her to
answer the question chairman durbin
thank you chairman why do you not want
the american people to know what
happened in the stuart case or any of
these cases chairman durbin i've never
seen
the chairman refuse to allow a witness
to answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want i
can just tell you at some point you have
to follow the rules okay will you let
her answer the question you've you've
been interrupting and by the way with
senator graham it went 10 minutes over
you've taken a big chunk of the time
will you allow her to answer the
question
you've given her why are you afraid of
her she's welcome to answer it right now
will you let her
senator coons
this is
really masterful stuff here from cruz
you can tell if you didn't already know
it before the guy has stage craft you
can tell that he's argued cases before
the supreme court every time durbin
tries to get the last word to insinuate
dishonestly that cruz doesn't want
katanji jackson to answer the question
cruz cuts back in no you won't let her
answer the question no you won't let her
answer no you won't no you want and it's
back and forth and back and forth and it
sounds like a middle school playground
but cruz is doing it for a reason
after cruz makes a scene and the clip
goes viral there is no mistaking it cruz
wants her to answer the question he
wants to give her time to do that durbin
wants her to keep her mouth shut and
durbin's right to do that because he
knows that katanji jackson's answers on
pedophiles on
life on womanhood they are not going to
play very well in peoria in just three
days katanji jackson has proven herself
to be either the stupidest nominee in
the history of the court or
the most radical
she will be confirmed there is almost no
question about that but she'll be
exposed too
as will every democrat who votes for her
i'm michael nolsas the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from william c who
says interesting that someone whose
nomination rested almost entirely on
being a woman
cannot define what a woman is that's not
fair
that is not fair
her nomination also rested on her being
black
that is not fair to biden made it very
clear he said i will pick a black
woman so it is ironic that someone who
is nominated half because she is a woman
cannot explain what a woman is but the
identity politics went a lot further
this clip has gone viral this this clip
we played it yesterday let's just play
it again uh marcia blackburn republican
senator from tennessee asked catanji
jackson
can you give a definition
of the word woman
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
is so unclear and controversial that you
can't give me
a definition
she can she's not a biologist this clip
has gone viral it's gone viral in part
because this gender issue has taken over
the country you see it with the ncaa
controversy there's a man named will
thomas who beat all the girls in the
girls swimming match and and he gets the
trophy and everyone's supposed to be
okay with that you see it with the
bathroom bills you see it with all sorts
of new legislation and conservatives are
flabbergasted by this we think this is
so
beyond caricature it's so beyond
absurdity
but i i am worried sometimes that we are
not giving the best argument for the
other side or that we simply don't
understand what the other side is saying
so in the interest of actually hearing
out the other side i'm very pleased to
bring on david pakman who is the host of
the david pakman show it's a nationally
syndicated progressive tv show and radio
show i'm always really grateful to
progressives who come on this show we
invite lots of them on very often they
say no sometimes they come on so just to
make sure we're not strawmanning
anything
let's bring on david david thank you so
much for coming on the show
it's a unique pleasure to be here
michael thank you so david
you saw the clip you've been watching
the katanji jackson hearings am i crazy
or should a twice harvard-educated
nominee federal judge nominee for the
supreme court
who is a woman
be able to define what a woman is
i can't say if you're crazy that would
be for a mental health for my doctor
you're either dishonest or ignorant and
we can maybe figure out which so so
here's the deal i mean i'm kind you know
what we're just meeting each other i'm
sort of kidding around but here's the
deal um
there are no uh instances where when
issues come before the supreme court
it comes down to the dictionary
definition of a word uh when it comes to
who counts as a woman or what is
discrimination or what is negligence
it's always in very narrow circumstances
where dictionary definitions do almost
nothing for you
so she was very smart
not to play into these kind of
rhetorical black holes because whatever
definition she gives michael
she then is going to be pushed into some
corner with some case or article or book
she hasn't read by the way uh and
there's no upside to it so if we're just
having a good faith conversation about
strategy
she did the right thing
almost 60 percent of americans believe
she's qualified and she is and that's
really all there is to it it's kind of
boring well i agree with her i don't
agree with you that it's boring i think
it's one of the most interesting
questions in the country that we're now
at a point where we can no longer even
define man or woman but i do agree with
you on strategy she's in a very tough
spot because her side of the aisle and
she's
relatively
leftist even by the standards of the
democratic party so on her side of the
aisle there is a new
definition of woman well they haven't
given the definition of woman but it's
it's not the old definition of woman
which is a person who's not a man that
is out because of the transgender
movement and so she knows that if she
gives this new definition which is a
woman is
i don't know a woman is someone who says
that he or she is a woman that's going
to alienate i think the majority the
vast majority of americans if she gives
the old definition that a woman is
a female human being and a female is of
or denoting the sex that can bear
children and reproduce
and you know produce eggs for instance
she knows that that will alienate her
base and she knows that that now is
apparently controversial in the law
after the boss stock decision after
other transgender decisions so i
understand the strategy
but what about the law what about the
definition you say she doesn't she
shouldn't be quoting the dictionary well
fine shouldn't she at least be able to
give the legal definition of a woman
shouldn't she a woman have some sense of
what that is i'm not a meteorologist i
can tell you if it's raining
yeah there is no legal definition of a
woman and that's exactly the point the
point here is when it comes to the court
the court is in a position or will be in
a position or might be in a position to
decide for the purposes of a particular
set of facts
based on a claim brought by someone who
appeals a case about these issues and so
it's it's literally irrelevant to her
job as a supreme court justice and so
again
we can have a cultural discussion
outside of the context of the supreme
court in the the senate's job in
evaluating is she qualified it's an
irrelevant question and by her
qualifications she's she's more
qualified than any of the nine justices
currently on the court there's no way to
deny that i think you can because i
think all of the nine justices on the
court can tell you what a woman is
saying so i know we're getting because
they've never been asked to do that no
nobody's ever been asked to define words
in this way during hearings so you could
speculate that but they've never been
asked they've never been asked
impossible i
i've never but i i i as a gambling man i
would bet the farm that justice alito
could tell you what a woman is but
you're right they've never been asked
because it's never been controversial
before but i want to get to a point you
just made you said there's no legal
definition of a woman but there must be
because there are legal protections
specifically for women so if we don't
know what a woman is then title three
thing
title nine title
is quite controversial good faith
conversation or one that's in some way
productive you know
you're saying you and i or you're saying
katanji jackson yeah i don't know if i
mean listen the republican senators
obviously didn't want to have a good
faith conversation i was i was talking
about you and i michael yes well i i do
want to i mean this this is why i'm
granting you the you're making the point
on political strategy i totally grant
you that that was the right move for her
to make if she wants to avoid it
but but then bring up title ix i mean
there are legal protections for women
this is coming before the court it's
come before the court in the last term
they're going to be a lot more cases
coming before the court coming up it
seems extraordinarily relevant that we
know what this woman thinks of these
issues and of a basic question of
biology and human nature what is a woman
i mean i i don't think that's a bad
faith question for the senators or for
me to ask no it's so it's not
necessarily bad faith but we have to be
able to as i what i hope are reasonable
people michael understand that in the
context of her role as a supreme court
justice it doesn't come down to a
biological opinion like dude is that can
you at least grant that piece it's true
that for what the supreme court decides
these are narrow issues where when it
comes to obamacare's constitutionality
which amy coney barrett never you know
would refuse to weigh in on or that what
with all of these things these are
really narrow legal decisions and there
is no way in which a dictionary
definition definition of terms does
anything for us well it might do
something but i grant your point a
little bit except that marcia blackburn
didn't ask for the biological definition
or the dictionary definition that's what
katanji jackson added she said i'm not a
biologist but all marcia blackburn asked
was just tell me what a woman is from a
legal perspective a constitutional
perspective a philosophical i mean
whatever whatever literally not what
marsha blackburn said i would encourage
you to pull the clip and identify she's
a name at which she said that she said
she didn't mention biology and she
didn't mention the dictionary she said
but you just asserted that she said she
wanted the legal and philosophical she
never said no no no no no no no no no i
didn't say that i said she no no i i
just said marsha blackburn asked for the
definition
any sort of definition that katanji
jackson could give of women she didn't
specified by you're backtracking i'm not
backtracking i'm not dishonest now i'm
not back first tell my background no no
no no no hold on a second let's let's be
clear
30 seconds ago you said marsha blackburn
didn't ask for the biological she
actually did the legal no no no no no no
no no no no no let me let me finish the
sentence
okay but you're misrepresenting what i
said i know i'm not i would encourage
the audience to rewind why i would
encourage that i would encourage that as
well but first but can i even get it out
i okay the problem with what you just
did michael is you just said blackburn
asked for the legal definition and i
said no she didn't you know said no
that's true she actually just knows for
the definition i'm sorry well then if if
either you misheard or it seemed that i
misspoke i'll be very clear she marcia
blackburn just said what's the
definition of a woman she didn't specify
anything else now you then said that
biology has no place here or that the
dictionary definition has no place but
that's not what marsha blackburn asked
for she just asked a simple question
that
in these supreme court hearings
the senators can ask the questions
however they want
and the nominees can answer them however
they want or not answer them my opinion
is this is my opinion and you can have a
different one and that's the great thing
about america michael uh my opinion is
that if you're interviewing for the job
of supreme court justice it's reasonable
to assume the questions have a legal
bearing as to your role on the court
given that
judge jackson was right
to
understand the point of the question is
to back her into a rhetorical corner
about legal definitions and she was
right to say it's not something i can
answer these are narrow
issues when they come before the court
and there's no reason that she would ask
such a question when i do you know this
guy jessie lee peterson have you heard
of him i know jesse lee peterson when i
was on with jesse he said to me david
define what love is and what a man is
and it's a it's a really common
rhetorical technique for the bad faith
right to start with just pick a word and
define it and use it to back someone
into a rhetorical corner it's a waste of
time michael let's t let's talk about
real issues please okay well i i think
that as a
philosophical issue but certainly is a
legal issue to the definition of a woman
does matter has mattered recently it
will matter soon but but i i i at least
agree with you on the stream you have
not convinced me of judge jackson's uh
good faith uh
confirmation hearing but you have uh
convinced me that she is a wise
politician
and that she's uh she's playing her hand
the best that she can
before i let you go david i know we're
like way over i
i'm not i'm really not playing the game
of giving you some impossible thing to
define but since the question of woman
is up in the air everyone's arguing over
what it means these days do you have
either you yourself or you speaking for
the progressives do you have a working
definition that you would use
no i don't do like i told jessie lee
peterson and there's so many that this
this interview is feeling a lot like
that one interestingly enough um i don't
do dictionary i do politics and so now i
just i don't spend time defining words
and here's here's the in all seriousness
michael yeah um
let's now talk philosophically really
we're talking you know man to man now
dictionaries are descriptive not
proscriptive so they're prescriptive
sometimes too but yeah but they can be
descriptive they can be they're
descriptive and prescriptive as well
right the word definition by definition
humans decide what to put in the
dictionary right so they're just the
these are scripted but they put it there
because the words at the time believe
yeah i mean we could we could go down a
tangent on prescriptivism versus
descriptivism and that might be good for
a future appearance to tangent i know it
would be a very good discussion and and
i i think would be great to have you
back i appreciate that i truly truly
appreciate your coming on and giving uh
the progressive perspective on this and
i hope to have you back on the show
where can people find you in the
meantime
davidpakman.com and it's been my
unbridled pleasure to provide you these
insights
thank you david very much i appreciate
it we need to get more progressives to
come on this show full-time and when i
want to hire someone you know where i go
ziprecruiter right now head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles according to the latest research
90 percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022. well if you need to
add more employees to your team you've
got to check out zip recruiters if
recruiter is the
way to hire we love zip recruiter here
at the daily wire we've gotten lots of
great employees through zip recruiter
zip recruiter is different than the
other job sites you're not just throwing
spaghetti at the wall you're not just
posting some job on a board and then
hoping for the best zip recruiters
powerful matching technology finds and
matches the right candidates up with
your job then it proactively presents
those candidates to you you review them
you find the recommended candidates and
then you can invite your top choices to
apply for your job this encourages
everything to move a lot faster time is
money and personnel is the most
important investment you can make find
the right employees right now for your
workplace with zip recruiter you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
katanji jackson has had a really tough
time on the supreme court confirmation
hearings she as we just discussed can't
define what a woman is she cannot define
when life begins she has this tough
issue where she's been light on
sentencing pedophiles
there's another issue that almost no one
is talking about and this
it's not the most radical thing she said
but it's pretty out there katanji
jackson
while she was
describing various cases that she has
heard as a judge
she praised a really radical cult called
the african hebrew
israelites even areas of the law that
you might think
apply only to businesses
impact real people
at times so this case involved a small
community a cultural community um of
people who believe in
vegan lifestyles um they call themselves
the african hebrew israelites but it's
not a religious community it's a
cultural community around
healthy living
and
they have created
a restaurant and a series of restaurants
here in the washington dc area
with menus involving really um
i'm told terrific vegan foods and in
this community
there was a
member
who was the one who created the recipes
and who was responsible for the
restaurant the whole community had other
aspects to it
it's a cultural community it's a vegan
community it's not religious the african
hebrew israelites this got my ears up
because i
have heard of the african hebrew
israelites sometimes called the black
israelites sometimes just called the
hebrew israelites and there are
different groups of them
but they're in new york they're in dc
they're all over the country they're
actually all over the world and it's a
group of black nationalists
who
believe that the jews are not really the
jews and that black people are actually
the jews the israelites described in the
bible and when you meet them in new york
and dc they're usually hurling all sorts
of vicious racial and sexual slurs at
people actually the covington kids you
remember the covington pro-life kids who
were yelled at by the crazy native
american man banging the drum well the
the group that first started yelling at
them was a group of the hebrew
israelites
katanji jackson is saying one they're
not religious to their you know this
nice wonderful community
seems very strange to me the left is
already running interference they're
saying conservatives are confusing black
israelite sects in labeling katanji
brown jackson as soft on anti-semitism
and they're saying well lots of people
like townhall.com and ben dominic and
other other conservatives are confusing
them yes there are the hebrew israelites
that are vicious and anti-semitic and
racist and terrible but then there are
the nice hebrew israelites and there are
different groups and you're an idiot if
you're confusing them so i just did
about five minutes of googling and
that's not true it's true that there are
different
associations in different sects of the
hebrew israelites
but
it it's it's not true
that they have different views on who
the real jews are and it's not true that
they're not a religious group you just
go to the specific group that was
involved in katanji jackson's case you
go to their website the african hebrew
israelites of jerusalem about us they
talk about their religious views the
very first line is most of the time
around the world when men speak of the
kingdom of god they do so metaphorically
but we do not we're talking in real life
so the very first line is a religious
line the historical background is that
they are the ancient israelites and then
they were driven uh to africa
and then from west africa they were
brought by the europeans on slave ships
so
this is the group this is the group that
believes that the jews are not really
the jews and the black people are the
real jews
they're obviously a religious community
it's not just a group of vegans it's not
just like your hippie sister who decides
she's not going to eat meat for a while
this is a group if they eat a vegan diet
it is coming out of their religious
underpinning and so it it brings us back
to this point about katanji jackson
either
she's the stupidest nominee that's ever
come before the court she doesn't know a
damn thing about any of the cases she's
worked on or even what a woman is
or
she's a liar and the most radical which
is it
i i fear that it is
the latter not great stuff when you want
to reach people you can you can do it
look katanji jackson's reaching a lot of
people right now from her senate
confirmation hearings we're reaching a
lot of people here on this podcast when
you want to reach people for your
business i would strongly recommend you
check out podium right now go to
podium.com
knowles if you have ever owned a
business if you've ever worked for a
business you know that time is money
time is one of the most important assets
that you've got so don't waste all day
playing phone tag podium will help you
reach your customers the list of
customers that you need to reach is not
going to get any shorter that's why
local businesses everywhere are turning
to podium podium makes every interaction
as easy as sending a text so everything
that makes your business great can get
done faster not just a better way to
communicate it's a better way to do
everything for your business gather
reviews collect payments even market to
your customers makes it all as easy as
pressing send when you use podium with
podium you will close more deals with
more customers before the competition
even has a chance to call them back join
right now the more than 100 000
businesses that already use podium to
streamline their customer interactions
get started for free at podium.com
knowles or sign up for a paid podium
account and get a free credit card
reader restriction supply that's
podium.com
knowles so katanji jackson has been
having this terrible terrible week in
her confirmation hearings
and then it finally came back to this
ish after the hebrew israelites after
the what is a woman thing after on and
on and on it finally came back to what
many consider the most damning
argument against her confirmation that
she's soft on kitty porn and and child
pornographers and she got a little hot
under the collar defending it
in comes the internet
on the internet with one click
you can receive you can distribute
tens of thousands
you can be doing this for 15 minutes and
all of a sudden
you are looking at 30 40 50 years in
prison
good
good
good allow her to finish please i hope
you go to jail for 50 years if you're on
the internet trolling for images of
children and sexual exploitation so you
don't think that's a bad thing i think
that's horrible that's what the witness
said that's not what the wit i mean i
guess it is sort of what the witness
said but anyway moving on moving on
gavel gavel gavel
this was an expertly laid trap and
katanji jackson fell into it because
this is what you really believe she says
look now it's so easy to spread child
pornography and so if you apply the same
sentence sentencing guidelines from
before the internet to the internet
people are going to go to jail for a
really long time and lindsey graham says
yeah good
isn't that good don't you want
child pornographers to go to jail for a
long time
and she says oh oops i just revealed i
don't and i don't think it's because
katanji jackson's a pedophile i think
it's because she's a radical i think
it's because she's an ideologue who
believes
that
criminals should face much lighter
sentences and who believes that we have
an over-incarceration problem and who
believes that we need criminal justice
reform and it's society's fault and we
need to go live and so whatever the
reason i mean you're talking about some
of the
more heinous offenders out here and even
for them she's saying we're going to go
a lot lighter so lots of red flags in
this woman's i'm sorry i'm not a
biologist i can't call her a woman lots
of red flags in this person's
hearing
and yet the
establishment left loves her joy behar
on the view says
this woman is
perfect
here you have a woman
katanji who reminded me of obama a
little bit because he he was also
perfect he had nothing wrong going on so
what you have here are 50 senators who
are going to vote against
this woman who is above reproach
and the first black woman in that
position that is going to be on their
record and that's why they're asking
these dumb questions so that they can
have something to bring back to their
constituency when they go home and say
well look at you know she doesn't
believe that babies are racist and
whatever the hell they were talking
about who even knows what they're
talking about but they need something
because it's an embarrassment to the
country to vote against a woman of this
caliber
she's perfect she she reminds me of
obama
she reminds you of a
she reminds you of obama because she's
black that's what you're saying
and she she brings it back to race at
the end too so first she goes this woman
she reminds me of obama and then i think
joy behar realized that she was making a
comment that was extremely condescending
and obviously very racial so she said
because they're both perfect
but then she brings it back to race at
the end right she says and black people
need to be perfect for these awful
racist republicans to get by that's
preposterous
a white person
in katanji
jackson's
with with her record with her background
would not be she wouldn't even be
nominated for the supreme court right
now we know that because joe biden
explicitly said i'm only going to pick a
black woman
we're going to get a diversity hire
there might be qualified white guys or
asian guys or hispanic guys or other
women but only a black woman
she says well you're at a disadvantage
if you're black no not according to not
according to joe biden not according to
affirmative action not according to the
law
so no and she because she's perfect well
let's see she can't define what life is
she's defending pedophiles and she
doesn't know what a woman is she herself
a woman doesn't sound all that perfect
to me just like obama he was perfect
barack obama is the chicago machine
politician
one of the more corrupt presidents not
the most corrupt one of the more corrupt
presidents we've had in recent memory
but he's perfect
no no drama obama no scandals on his
watch like the irs targeting scandal
channeling the federal bureaucracy
against your political opponents like
the fast and furious scandal like the
benghazi skin like no he's perfect
forget about it hear no evil see no evil
no way
the whole motivation
the whole motivation here to support
this woman
is for her race and for her sex her sex
that she cannot even
define
this this brings me to
speaking of women and speaking of
perfection nancy pelosi devout
practicing catholic
nancy pelosi
nancy has just come out to defend what
we are told is the women's issue now
abortion and she says she is defending
abortion as a devout practicing catholic
again it isn't about what is your
religious belief
it's what is the right of people to make
their own decisions about the sizing and
time it or if they're going to have a
family
this really gets me burned up
in case you didn't notice because again
i'm very catholic with devout practicing
all of that
they would like to throw me out but i'm
not going
because i don't want to make their day
they want to throw me out of the
catholic church but i'm not going
anywhere because i'm a devout practicing
catholic if you're a devout practicing
catholic why do they want to throw you
out
because you're not a devout practicing
catholic because you don't believe in
the teachings of the catholic church you
don't practice the catholic faith and
because you nancy pelosi are in a state
of public scandalous grave mortal sin
that imperils your eternal soul with
every breath that you waste every
unrepentant breath that you waste
defending the slaughter of babies that's
why
you do i know that we're living in this
post-modern world now where we get to
define anything as anything else and
words have no meaning that was actually
part of what david and i were talking
about he said words are just whatever we
say they are right that was the
descriptivism prescriptivism debate we
if i say i'm a woman i'm a woman well
how do you define that well i can't
define it because it's just whatever i
want it to be
that's a very new very silly very modern
idea
and whatever else you want to say about
the catholic church it's not a new and
modern institution and you don't just
get to say i'm a catholic there's a
group called catholics for choice
it's a group of pro-abortion
apostate catholics i guess
and
they're obviously not practicing and
they say well
i can be a catholic if i say i am no
you can't catholicism christianity
traditionally relies on
the sacrament of baptism and you're
practicing the faith and you can be
excommunicated and you can be in a state
of grave mortal sin and and
nancy pelosi's either got to get right
with her faith or acknowledge that she
doesn't really adhere to the faith of
catholicism she adheres to the faith of
leftism she's happy to use catholicism
and christianity when it suits her
purposes but but when push comes to
shove when those
rival gods come come into conflict she
is going to choose
the gods of her own desires and whims
and and political ideology of
leftism now when you want to
store up treasure not merely in heaven
though that's ultimately where you
should store up treasure but you also
want to take care of your treasure here
on earth i would strongly recommend you
check out alto ira right now go to alto
altoira.com
michael a lot of people are getting
really interested in crypto right now
cryptocurrency might represent the
future of money especially with our
dollar basically being worth nothing
these days it's one of the most exciting
investment opportunities to come around
for a long time
but what about taxes some people like me
are dealing with this right now because
tax season rolls around and no one
really knows what to do with taxes and
crypto well now we have the answer with
alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and you can avoid or defer
the taxes get into investing in crypto
do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account alto's crypto ira is the easy
way to get crypto into an ira trade all
you want no tax headache create an
account in a few minutes and invest with
as little as 10 bucks and no setup
charges you get secure trading 24 7
through alto's integration with coinbase
there are more than 80 coins available
bitcoin ethereum you know open an alto
crypto ira account with as little as 10
bucks go to alto ira.com michael that's
a
ltoira.com mich a e l start investing in
cryptocurrency today that is alto
ira.com
michael
this issue of what is a woman
has become
a national phenomenon i i was just
debating with
david pakman he couldn't give the
definition or he it's not that he
wouldn't give the definition because as
he admitted politically this is a total
loser for the left because they don't
have a definition for it
marsha blackburn asked this question
well our very own matt walsh has been
working stealthily for many months now
on a secret mission on a movie a man
going all over
to answer one simple question
what is a woman
i have traveled all over the world
for the past year
asking one simple question
what is
a woman
what is a woman what is it what is it i
don't know
people are laughing is that is that a
dumb question
i've been asking everybody this and
almost nobody can answer it what is a
woman what is a woman that's a great
question
[Music]
if one person could tell me what a woman
is
congressman thank you for for being here
i think this interview is over let's
turn off the cameras i just wanted to
know what is a woman
it's not a complicated question
it's not a complicated question but it
is a very very complicated
answer apparently and matt has
i don't think he's gotten it yet we'll
see the movie's coming out soon it's
going to be absolutely terrific we as
conservatives need to be able to give an
answer
because matt kicked off this trend now a
lot of people are catching on to it
senator blackburn and others
but what's the answer
there is an answer you know
despite david not
giving it
earlier despite the katanji jackson not
giving it earlier there is an answer a
woman is an adult
female human
uh but michael what is a female right
that's that would be the next question a
female is of
or denoting the sex
that
can bear children
or produce eggs
but michael you say
not all women
are fertile not all women can bear
children that's true michael not all
women
can even produce eggs that's exceedingly
rare that a woman can't produce any eggs
but
sure it can happen
that still doesn't change the definition
because those women
are still of the sex that can bear
children and produce eggs they are not
men what is a man a man is an adult male
human being this is amazing that in the
year of our lord 2022 we have to give
these definitions because america has
forgotten it a male is or a man is an
adult
male human what is a male a male is of
or denoting the sex
that produces
mobile gametes small mobile gametes
especially sperm
that can impregnate a woman
that can fertilize an egg
that's well what about a man whose
swimmers don't work they remain of
the sex that can do those things they
are not
women who
have a different definition this is
what happens when you open the
dictionary and you just look at the
definition for now the definition is
going to change this is where david
pakman makes a very good point he says
sometimes definitions just change based
up to just on describing how we use
words that's true but the definition
that has existed from the dawn of time
until five minutes ago and it's still in
the dictionaries because the libs
haven't changed them yet
says that that is what a man is and that
is what a woman is why does the
dictionary say that david as he pointed
out in his descriptivism comments would
say well it just says that because
that's what human beings agreed upon but
that's not true
it is it is true that sometimes words
evolve over time and the politically
correct try to change words to
contradict their meaning but also
words have definitions because because
they refer to something that is actually
real a word is a symbol and it refers to
the symbolized which is a real thing and
a man is a real thing and a woman is a
real thing
and that definition really really
matters this is not just some frivolous
joke this is not just some bad faith
discussion this is not just matt walsh
getting some laws by making a movie this
is not just republicans scoring cheap
points by asking an unfair question
during a senate hearing this is a
bedrock question for our law and for our
self-understanding there are a lot of
laws that refer to protections for men
and women if the definition of woman
suddenly becomes man those protections
completely go away if we as a society
can't even agree on what the work on
what any words mean we can't communicate
and govern ourselves but surely if we
can't agree on the most basic
definitions of the most basic aspects of
life then we don't have a society then
we are just babbling in a cacophonous
void and increasingly that's what our
country feels like which is not not
great okay it gets it gets my blood up
it gets me hungry for political action
and when i'm
hungry
for real food i turn to tessa mays right
now go to tessamays.com promo code
michael what if
eating healthy also tasted great
these seem like they are completely in
conflict with each other but they're not
thanks to tessa mays tessa mays found a
way with their award-winning ranch
dressings and vinaigrettes to make
healthy food taste great tessamese is an
american-made company started by three
brothers with a dream to share their
mom's recipes with the world tessame's
tastes great they put flavor and quality
above all else and because of that they
quickly became the number one organic
dressing brand in the country all of
their products are manufactured here in
the u.s of a which i love and they have
a wide variety of anything you want
kosher whole30 keto products what you
you want it they'll have it for you
whether you're in the mood for a creamy
avocado ranch or a light refreshing
lemon garlic dressing and marinade there
is a testament product for every
occasion kids parents and grandparents
can all agree on one thing tessame's
dressings are good on everything dipping
wings pizza pouring it on a salad tessa
maze makes every meal better these guys
are the embodiment of the american dream
they're bringing manufacturing back to
america their products most importantly
taste great go to tessamays.com
use promo code michael for 15 off their
their terrific products
t e s s e
m a e s dot com promo code michael we
also i've talked to you we've got a lot
of projects at daily wire
i've talked to you about what i think is
now
i think it's the most popular
content we've ever put for the daily
wire members
this is fouchy unmasked this is my
three-part series streaming now
exclusively at the daily wire the true
story of dr fauci check it out
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way the 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
the series factionmast is screaming now
at
dailywire.com go check it out
dailywrite.com subscribe head on over
there today we'll be right back with a
lot more
it seems like our whole culture
is
changing
being upended
being reset
the world economic forum has called for
a great reset specifically around the
covid lockdowns
you've heard for years conspiracy
theories crazy tinfoil hack conspiracy
theories about a new world order
those nuts who mention the new world
order
which
president george h.w bush
talked about which lots of leading
statesmen have talked about in our
history and which president joe biden
mentioned just the other day
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four
generations as one of them as the one of
the top military people said to me in a
secure meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and
since then we established a liberal
world order and that hadn't happened in
a long while a lot of people died but
nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've got to unite the
rest of the free world and doing it
new world order so when you hear this
phrase everyone's eyes open everyone's
ears perk up what are you talking about
a new world order i thought that wasn't
real i thought that was a crazy
conspiracy theory well
biden is referring to one and what is it
i don't think that the new world order
is reptilians from mars dressed up in
human suits maybe hillary maybe bill
maybe fauci they
i'm not sold that they are not
reptilians dressed up in human suits but
for most of the people talking about
this i think they're ordinary
people
with utopian
and terrible goals
when george h.w bush was talking about
the new world order what was he talking
about he was talking about
the end of the cold war this new period
of
american hegemony all around the world
we're the sole superpower we're going to
run everything and things are going to
be great and how are they going to be
great basically through the expansion of
global markets so we're going to spread
a
we're going to spread globalism we're
going to spread
the american
economic and political order all the way
around the world uh their regimes are
going to have to get much more
democratic much more open to free trade
if they're not well there might be some
problems for those regimes we might have
to topple those regimes and that'll be
unpleasant there will be some wars but
once that happens once we topple all the
autocrats then we're going to have this
free flourishing liberal democratic
world and we're all going to live in
peace and harmony kumbaya and we pursued
that policy for a very long time
a lot of the wars in the middle east had
that idea
underpinning them a lot of the
economic policies regarding china
allowing china into the world trade
organization
really normalizing relations with china
the idea was well if we open up trade
with china that's going to make the
regime less autocratic how has that
worked out not very well how did the
predictions that joe biden specifically
made the rising china would be great for
the world great for china great for
everyone that that didn't work out very
well but they keep pushing it because
they believe that um unless the entire
world is basically operating under the
same kind of political regime and
economic regime then there's going to be
war and so that's so we need we need war
so that we can prevent the war in the
future that was the idea it's a very
utopian kind of idea and it hasn't
worked out very well i would humbly
recommend
rather than continuing to pursue the new
world order
maybe we look at some of the older world
orders
you know maybe we make our goals a
little more
realistic we have a little bit more
humility in our goals because if we get
a little too ambitious and we want to
remake the entire world in the image of
america we might end up losing america
we might end up losing our borders we
might end up losing our culture we might
end up losing our solidarity and our
love of country we might end up losing
our minds to the point that we can't
even just define what a baby is and what
a woman is
oh that's all already happened right
maybe
we need a little less ambitious of a
foreign policy and a little more care
and attention paid not to the global
citizens of the world where borders
don't matter
but to the citizens of the united states
and recognize you're not going to get
rid of wars you're not going to get rid
of autocrats you're not going to solve
centuries sometimes millennia-long
conflicts with some platitudes that came
out of a 1960s economic textbook from
the united states that maybe
the these long-simmering issues in the
middle east in africa in eastern europe
in crimea for that matter that these are
a little more complicated
and we
they require a little bit more humility
because now things are really spiraling
out of control there's a a politician
who wants to go back in time
but to a very specific period of time
this is a russian politician
parliament member oleg mach matt vachev
who usually speaks on behalf of the
kremlin and he dropped this idea during
an appearance on russian state tv
according to the daily mail he wants to
take back alaska
see alaska used to belong to the
russians and then america got alaska and
now
this guy wants alaska back for russia he
says he demands the return of all
russian properties those of the russian
empire the soviet union and current
russia which has been seized in the
united states and so on
that was my next point
alaska we want antarctica
we discovered it so it belongs to us
this
russian parliament member mr oleg
sounds pretty much indistinguishable
from an american liberal an american
campus liberal who who signs their
emails you know assigned so and so i
acknowledge that i am on the land of the
chikani tribe and this is our land their
land that was taken unjustly but you
know the we need to give the land back
to the indians or back to the mexicans
or back to the french i don't know but
we need to whoever else was here before
us anyone but america gets the land
my favorite part is when they say we
have to give the land back to the
indians the question is well which
indians
this they even when they put it in their
signatures they say i acknowledge i'm on
the land
that was formerly belonged to the apache
and the comanche and the this she and
the that chi and you say okay well how
did the land belong to all of those
people
they all just shared it they were all
kind of just one it
oh no that the land belongs to those
tribes at different times well why did
the land change possession
oh right because the comanche came in
and took it from the apache
oh okay so are we are we going to give
it back to the apache or we're going to
give it back to the comanche
or we're just going to keep it ourselves
because we took it from the comanche
how come
the comanche get to take it but we don't
get to take it
how come the law of conquest
works for every other
group in the history of the world except
for us
are we going to give it back to the
russians
the american left after simping for
russia for a hundred years now they are
pretending to hate russia and accusing
the conservatives are being pro-russia
but what are we going to do are we going
to give it back to the russians i don't
think so mr oleg i think there's
something called finders keepers
and buyers keepers and secretary of
state seward bought that land for us and
we're going to keep it
and good luck if you want to invade the
land your invasion of of ukraine which
everyone thought was going to be so
swift and oh here come the russians well
you're bogged down in that so good luck
go invade russia go bring it on bring it
on buddy i don't think so
if we're if we're going to return to a
more stable sane humble foreign policy
then we should be a little more
realistic
this russian parliament member seems
more ambitious and crazy than woodrow
wilson than
george w bush in his most wilsonian
initiatives but far far crazier than all
of that
where's the justification you know pope
francis
i do want to get to this before we go
pope francis says
not only is the war in ukraine not just
but there is no such thing as a just war
and far be it for me to contradict papa
francesco
but let's not forget that the pope is
only infallible when he's not being
fallible he's infallible on a narrow
range of issues and pope francis has
said a war is always always the defeat
of humanity always there is no such
thing as a just war they do not exist
this would contradict millennia of
catholic teaching thomas aquinas in
particular the great saint and doctor of
the church says there is such a thing as
a just war of course there is
that the the justice though relies on a
few things it relies on authority the
person waging the war has the authority
to do so it relies on a just cause
you can't wage a war even if you're an
authority you can't wage a war just
because you wanna there has to be a just
cause for the war self-defense would be
one example
and there has to be rightful intention
so those are the
the criteria there so
it's true that war is a bad thing
but it doesn't mean that there's never a
purpose to war or that war
taken for just aims is not
justified it's not is not legitimate it
reminds me of the people who say
violence never solves anything
you think well it solved the second
world war
it solved uh well it sounds like it
solves crime when the police come and do
violence upon criminals that solves that
we seem to have forgotten that the left
seems to have forgotten that katanji
jackson maybe never knew that in the
first place these are really
really basic things
what is justice there's a definition
what is justice it's giving to each what
he deserves
what is
a woman a woman is an adult female human
being
what is
justified what is life when does life
begin these are really basic questions
contrary to what the left is trying to
confuse you into today
the definitions of those questions
the definitions of those terms matter
we will have a definition we will
operate according to some definition the
left wants to radically change the
definition
we will have some definition or other
if we have the wrong definition that is
not going to lead to a flourishing
society i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bourie supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show